and katmandu tony gonzalen is making his
eighth appearance his seventh start the
dodgers still hoping he could stretch
out
longer into games and more innings
pitched and resting of course the
bullpen along the way 1-0 in the 213 era
if i have one thing to talk about with
tony gonzalon i would just tell him
trust your stuff so wade in scoring
position for mikey stremski one of the
hottest giants hitters sprung on and
missed strike three stripski down on
strikes good splitter trust your stuff
gone slam with a fastball he can vary
the speeds on it he averages right at 93
and for that splitter he throws it
almost 30 percent of the time but when
it is on it is really good one on one
out and back into the lineup is buster
posey and it's great to see him back the
last sunday before the all-star break a
week before the all-star break was when
buster got hurt so it's been a while
since we've seen him in the lineup that
one is hit deep down the line into the
corner
[Applause]
buster posey
returns in a big way
boom
two-nothing giants
a laser beam over the left field wall
his 13th home run of the year and the
giants lead two to nothing thank
goodness
it was called to strike the pitch before
instead of a walk a two-run homer yeah
we missed that guy kind of a hanger a
slider and posey was on it just tattooed
it down the left field line the only
question was did he hook it and it
really it didn't have much hook on it at
all just hit hard well that is the way
to start a series want to know to wilmer
flores with still only one out now a
swing and a high drive left field wilmer
got this one on its way gone
halfway up the bleachers
back-to-back homers for the giants
three-nothing
and the giants have two home runs in a
row posey then flores
three-nothing giants
that was a big fly that was
nutted better first one gone the hitters
solano grills one to center field
sprinting in is fillinger who makes a
spectacular sliding catch
just on top of the blades of grass in
center and that immediately wasting no
time
our judges declare that the dodger
defensive player of the game on the hill
tonight for the giants will be the
right-hander kevin gausman gosman
this year making start number 19 and
what a half he had nine and three with a
173 era put him on the all-star team in
29 at bats against the giants this
season max muncie's hit seven home runs
he's got 21 home runs total
[Applause]
[Applause]
his 22nd home run of the year
58 runs batted in wow now here's justin
turner and turner with a fly ball and
the dodgers say back to back
back to back this got posey and floors
in the top half of the first you got
muncie and turner in the
[Applause]
well denver had a home run derby
[Applause]
one week ago tonight
the dodgers stadium looks like we got
one going on tonight that was a mistake
and turner makes gaussman pay it's a
one-run game and buster posey comes up
posey who ripped a two-run homer down
the left-field line in his first at-bat
now up with two on and two out
in this strike three and that will end
the ending no runs one hit two left will
go to the bottom of the second with the
giants leaving the dodgers three to two
dodgers who have hit nine grand slams
this year
giants fit five that's a big number nine
is a really big number this one is swung
on it strike three great splitter there
and he gets through it
wow that was the one he's looking for
and he strikes out will smith the
dodgers load them up but they leave him
floated and they do not score we'll go
to the third dodger debut in colorado
pitch to scoreless and now faces the
team that cut him loose earlier this
year dodgers claimed him off waivers
from san francisco
a couple of days off of the ninth pitch
inning
they come at you with a fast ball it's
going to hover around 95. he's got a
slider that's down there in the low 80s
here's jazz standing again sure two men
on one man out the pitch ground ball the
first once he throws to second out at
second on the first safe
shurfy was covering the bag would have
been a nice three six one double play
stremski runs well now runners at the
corners and two out the ground ball to
short
third hop taylor picks it up throws to
first that's where he'll do it no runs
no hits two walks two left it looks like
jimmy sure if he's gonna back for
himself sherfie's first trip to the
plate trophy shoots knocked
to get him to out as it rolls off his
glove he gets it and then flips the ball
to the tail covering in time for the out
who's back that was it jimmy broke and i
mean
[Music]
giants three dodgers two alex dickerson
has walked and single to right
[Applause]
what a play
just perfect timing
the top of his leap and gets it enough
to rob gramps
stakes are higher now a base hit could
knock in a run here's dugger left in
there to back for himself against the
left-hander sharply hit right side
stopped by turtle springs to his feet
and throws him out
chris taylor with a heck of a play
and it stays 3-2 at the halfway point so
if the strata is second and slater at
first darren rough bats
grounds it to first muncie will throw to
second for the fourth out there the
quarterback prefers a double play
oh beautifully done muncie to mckinstry
and then to bickford covering it first
and so just like that bickford and out
away from getting out of this with no
damage and a hanging slider that he pops
out
right out to second base is taylor and
he's got it the jacks are one for nine
with runners in scoring position
now jason vossler with the bases loaded
and one out that's where you really
start to feel like the game's kind of on
the line this is a huge situation
bossler hits a high drive right field
rex going back into the corner on the
warning track he will make the catch
tagging from third is posey here comes
the throw it is laid in offline posey
scores it's four to two giants and now
tyro estrada right-handed hitter will
bat with two down giants ahead by two
pulled hard on the ground in fair by the
third baseman down the left field line
dickerson's in to score solano racing
around third he gets the go sign the
relay from taylor to the plate is too
late solano scores tyro estrada into
second with a two run double
and the giants lead is six to two
slater's got a hit tonight and he's only
at bat so far that's a base hit down the
right field
another rbi scoring is estrada it's a
four run inning seven to two giants man
all the frustrations of the last four
days
of getting hits in these kinds of
situations and the giants are taking it
out on the dodger bullpen right now the
giants in front getting three in the
first and four in the seventh
fly ball
toward the right field corner slicing
toward the line and making a spectacular
catch is zach rick sliding into the
sidewall he's probably got some pebbles
in his pants
on that
the track
for the terrific play
is out
who sets the target up here's the 1-2
pitch fastball in on the hands kind of a
broken bat squibber towards the right
side over the fielded rough he'll throw
to first mcgee gets to the bag ahead of
pujols that's the final out of the ball
game and the giants have finished off a
series opening win